welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and spider-mans tragic departure
from the MCU has posed so many questions
about his future on-screen I gave some
initial thoughts on it last week and
then we went deeper into it in rogue
theory you go check that out but
honestly it's hard for me to discuss
this without getting screamed at by one
of the four Spider Men on Hollywood
Boulevard
they got running shoes real fast but I'm
gonna break down to the latest spider
gait updates and present what I think
Sony's future spider verse could look
like and please don't get mad at me for
speculating about a future that you just
don't want at this moment because hey it
could still be a future that we actually
end up really digging so quick recap
last week deadline reported that Disney
had approached Sony with an offer to
increase their financing and profit
share for their co-produced spider-man
movies from 5 percent to 50 percent for
future collaborations that Kevin Feige
would oversee an offer that Sony flatly
rejected and actually further reports
said that Disney's offer was more
reasonable something around 25% sony
meanwhile seems to be pointing the
finger at Feige for being too busy
focused on other Marvel projects and
actually some reporting has suggested
that Disney execs like Alan Bergman
wanted Feige to focus on incoming Fox
Marvel reboots like the mutants and
Fantastic Four rather than spending all
of his time and energy making billions
for a rival studio Sony that Disney
would only get a piece of since Disney
already owns all the merchandise scene
for the spider-man brand like the very
profitable toys and the ability to get
churros with the spider-man without
running shoes in a fanny pack at
Disneyland Disney is already making
plenty of billions from this character
so you could see how their profit driven
suits may feel like they have enough
leverage to just walk now there were
some rumors in recent days that a secret
deal between Disney and Sony was going
to reveal the d23 it did not happen and
the details did sound way too good to be
true they're saying there was a deal for
6 to 7 Kevin Feige Tom Hollands
spider-man movies which would follow
Peter through college and beyond meeting
friends like Firestar Iceman and the
future Avengers in Fantastic Four in
which Marvel would co-financed for 30%
and get exclusive rights to stream
spider-man anticip less and venom would
go to the MCU and Marvel would go
produce all the live-action spider-man
spin-offs and all of us get Tesla's I
mean I'm all for wishful thinking folks
but seriously I mean I hate to break it
to you but that deal probably
isn't happening in fact most recently
Kevin Feige and Tom Holland have opened
up and seemed to confirm spider-man in
the MCU is indeed over Feige said the
deal was never meant to last forever and
that he was thankful to tell the story
he always wanted to tell Holland said
that the future of spider-man will be
different but will be equally as awesome
and amazing and Holland probably said
that while fighting the urge to spoil
something anything Holland has also said
that he sat down any pitch meeting for
spider-man 3 and promised it would be
something very special and very
different Tom Holland is still attached
for two more spider-man movies at Sony
now there are reports that Marvel is
actually trying to court away director
John watts let's think Tom Holland had
his word that the future of spider-man
could still be equally as awesome and
amazing with some new ways to make it
even cooler because Holland is right
like I have loved what Kevin Feige in
the Marvel Studios team have done with
the Peter Parker character and they have
been far more consistent in quality than
Sony alone ever was with highs like end
of the spider-verse
but also low low lows like the amazing
spider-man 2 but even at Marvel's best
which has been real good the MCU has
still been a bit hamstrung to showcase
Peters full cinematic potential like
spider-man isn't just supporting comic
relief to conflicts between grownups
there's also a lot more to him than a
struggle to define himself outside of
the shadow of Tony Stark in the Avengers
like I'm not saying Feige wouldn't have
made Peter the Marvel front man in his
MCU maybe that would have been his face
forward phase 5 plan if this Sony deal
went through but the fact of the matter
is Sony owns the rights to all of the
characters in Peters world and that it's
not changing Sony is a profitable movie
studio the only way that they would sell
spider-man by far their most valuable
character to Disney is if Sony and like
wanted to leave the filmmaking business
altogether and like go back to selling
Playstations TVs headphones now that
might happen someday just not anytime
soon because Sony has at least in one
recent instance proven its ability to
hire creators who understand what makes
spider-man's world special spider-man
into the spider verse in my eyes is the
closest a movie has gotten to a true
spider-man film and not just because of
the vibrant animation this movie
introduced a seemingly infinite world of
interesting characters it's funny the
action is great the story is compelling
and the teen angst of the hero is the
driving force of the narrative it's not
the dismissed B story that Peter Parker
has to swing away from and we all forget
about while he's playing with the
grown-ups this isn't meant as a
criticism of the MCU spider-man so far
it's just been kind of hard for them to
put Peter Parker in iron man's world and
not have Iron Man be in the spotlight of
it so let's just imagine that Sony is
capable of learning lessons from Feige
successes with him in the MCU and that
Sony might be able to trust creative
minds like those behind into the spider
verse to roll out a slate of spider-man
films that might fulfill Tom Hollands
promise based on what we know right now
with the right writers and directors
attached Sony's live-action spider-verse
could be even more exciting than
Marvel's announced for let's start with
spider-man 3 as Tom Holland said it is
in development far from home writers
Chris McKenna and Eric summers who are
super talented dudes
have already started writing the script
and before the break-up Kevin Feige
mention that the story would center
around Peter Parker as a person really
this Sony spider-man 3 would not require
Peter to like reset his reality or
anything he could still live in New York
just picking up where things left off
and far from home and just not address
any of the specific things that tied him
to Tony start so other than a depressing
breakup between Aunt May and happy Hogan
Peter Parker story going forward is
already largely severed from connections
to the MCU it sounds like it's more
about conflicts with entities that Sony
owns the exclusive rights to like Jay
jonah Jameson now Peter Parker would not
get to use Tony Stark's iron spider
armor probably ever again but really
building his own new suits has always
been what Peter Parker's all about as I
speculated before this spider-man 3
could be true Peter Parker trying to
clear his name while dealing with a new
villain perhaps Flash Thompson in a kind
of Harry Osborn role with far from home
hinting at some background family drama
forum maybe this could tie in things
like Norman Osborn Oscorp and the Green
Goblin but when it comes to films
currently on the schedule Sony does have
a Morbius the living vampire movie and
the works with Jared Leto coming July
2020 and then after that the next movie
on their lineup is venom 2 coming
October 2020 which will be directed by
Andy Serkis and after all this we could
be looking at a venom spider-man
crossover as in the comics this could
feature these enemies joining forces to
defeat an even worse threat carnage with
Woody Harrelson established as Cletus
Kasady
and the venom post-credits scene now I
will say it would probably take a bit of
elbow grease to adjust to Tom Hardy's
Eddie Brock it is someone that we could
possibly see in a movie
alongside Tom Hollands Peter Parker well
then again I never would have thought
Moody hunk Thor could be taken by the
quirky director of hunt for the wildered
up with Hulk and one of the best buddy
comedy superhero movies ever and yeah I
could see Andy Serkis pulling it off too
and by the way another benefit a venom
spider-man carnage movie could also be
more violent with an r-rating whereas
Disney has said r-rated content will not
be on their Disney Plus platform now
I'll get to the other movies that could
fill out this sony's spider-verse late
well before we continue thank you to our
sponsor Skillshare for helping us make
this episode Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills can explore
classes and everything from photography
and creative writing to marketing
productivity and more it's premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
high-quality classes from experts
working in their fields to help you gain
new skills to live your best life I have
actually kind of embraced my inner Peter
Parker lately by taking up amateur
photography so I have gotten a lot out
of the Skillshare course street
photography capture the life of your
city taught by the cool cityscape
photographer trash and just be careful
snapping photos of the spider-man on
Hollywood Boulevard I think will chase
you down and demand $10 steel chair is
also incredibly affordable especially
when compared to pricy in-person classes
or workshops and annual subscription of
Skillshare is less than ten dollars a
month and because Skillshare sponsoring
this episode you will receive a two
month free trial by clicking on the link
of the description just go to sk o sh
slash new rock stars 14 click on the
link in the description below
ok back to this spider-verse lineup we
also have heard reports that Sony is
developing a Nightwatch film written by
the showrunner of Luke Cage and a Kraven
the hunter film adapted from the Cravens
last stand comic storyline in which
Kraven seemingly kills spider-man and
takes on his suit an identity it's
really one of the best spider-man
stories in the comics and that brings us
to a sinister six movie so spider-man
homecoming in spider-man far from home
hath hinted at several villains who
could make up a live-action sister 6
including vulture scorpion shocker a
number of others really all they would
need is a leader who could be a not
actually dead Mysterio or a new villain
like Doc Ock or Green Goblin who could
be revealed in spider-man 3 director
Drew Goddard was originally scheduled to
make a sinister six film for Sony before
the deal with Marvel went into effect in
since the
he was briefly attached to shoot an
x-force film for Fox but now that the
Disney Fox merger is affecting
Deadpool's future Godard may once again
to be available there have also been
discussions about black cat and silver
sable movies and of course an animated
sequel to into the spider-verse in
addition to a Spider Woman spin-off with
when Stacy so really when he plot all of
these out along egg sony spider-verse
line up I gotta say if it's led by
talented creatives like McKenna and
summers Andy Serkis Drew Goddard Lord
Miller
these titles could prove to the world
that others cinematic universes besides
the one with the Big M in front of it
could be successful of course that is
until five years from now when they
mouth singularity monopolizes all
entertainment and we all become slaves
to Disney who crosses over Tom Hollands
spider-man with Will Smith genie they
like get married and adopt them up if
80s and we love it do you think this
Sony spider-verse could actually be
something that you enjoy alongside the
MCU
or you determined to boycott anything
that is incredible with Kevin Tigers PG
a comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on twitter and instagram at
Ieva subscribe to new rock stars for
more spider-man updates thank you for
joining me and whatever shock or
confusion you feel during this time at
a-hole pales in comparison how Jeff
Goldblum reacted to the news there may
be a little divorced happening nope this
is the first I've heard of it I'm
crestfallen
[Music]